in response to its violent invasion of
ukraine western nations have imposed a
series of powerful penalties on russia
and those penalties have started to hit
the russian economy hard
here's how sanctions and other measures
are rippling through russia affecting
everyone from president vladimir putin
to everyday russian citizens
first let's rewind to the beginning of
the conflict when putin first announced
a military operation in ukraine the west
responded with a first round of
penalties including blacklisting some
russian banks and halting the nordstream
2 pipeline those first moves sent a
message but the russian ruble and
russian markets were relatively stable
then as russian forces closed in on kiev
the us the eu and other western allies
ramped up the pressure they sanctioned
putin himself and other russian
officials freezing their assets overseas
then as the violence across ukraine
escalated and ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski pleaded for more help
the u.s and its allies imposed the most
powerful penalties to date they
sanctioned russia's central bank making
it hard for it to sell its foreign
currency reserves in other words the
sanctions prevent it from using its
rainy day fund to prop up the ruble and
those countries agreed to cut some of
russia's private banks off from the
swift global payment network why do
these moves matter because they
effectively stop the flow of money into
and out of russia that cripples russian
banks but it also severely limits
moscow's ability to manage the economy
and cushion the blow that third round of
sanctions sent the russian ruble
plunging and on monday it had one of its
biggest one-day drops ever nervous
citizens were photographed lining up at
banks and atms to withdraw cash a weaker
currency means a lower standard of
living and anything that's imported into
russia like phones and electronics are
about to get a lot more expensive and
that's why the spiraling ruble is
expected to stoke inflation which was
already high at 8.7 percent in russia in
january one former russian central bank
official told the journal that inflation
could rise by five percentage points so
if russians step on the breaks and stop
spending as much on goods and services
you could see factories close and
businesses shudder and the entire
russian economy shrink of course the
russian government doesn't want any of
this it wants to limit the impact of
sanctions so it has responded by
imposing capital controls it temporarily
closed the moscow stock exchange
preventing anyone from selling stocks it
also prohibited citizens from moving
their money to banks outside of the
country and the bank of russia doubled
its benchmark interest rate hiking it
from 9.5 percent to 20 on monday
the goal of that move is to encourage
people to put their money into russian
banks where they'll earn more interest
because russian banks have all but been
cut off from the rest of the world but
higher interest rates aren't necessarily
a good thing for russian citizens and
businesses higher interest rates mean
it's going to cost a lot more to borrow
money plus dramatic moves by a central
bank tend to intensify fears of a
financial crisis beyond sanctions
western companies have begun cutting
ties with russia for example apple
stopped all product sales in the country
disney halted the release of movies
there us venues pulled russian alcohol
and volvo stopped doing business in
russia russian businesses and citizens
are also facing other consequences due
to this war like restrictions on travel
because russian planes are now banned
from flying in a number of countries
russian officials have acknowledged the
financial pain but there's no sign that
the sanctions will force president putin
to pull his troops out of ukraine which
of course is the ultimate goal as he
criticized the sanctions monday putin
called the u.s and its allies an empire
of lies
so do you think the u.s and its allies
should go even further with sanctions
leave me a comment below and if you
found this video informative be sure to
subscribe to the channel i'll see you
next time
you